[Music]
over the weekend Michelle Obama and Matt
Damon were some of the celebrities who
gave commencement speeches to college
graduates yeah Matt Damon spoke at MIT
and the first lady spoke at City College
in New York City but they weren't the
only ones this is kind of cool Andy I
understand you gave a commencement
speech over the weekend I I did it went
really well and actually if you don't
mind I'd like to show some footage from
it if that's okay there's no time anyway
oh I'm kidding I'm kidding
for God's sake for God's sake I think
we'd all like to see Andy's commencement
speech
[Applause]
yeah
No yeah yeah if only we had the time all
right now
here's my commencement speech the world
is a big place an exciting place and yes
sometimes a dangerous place but each of
you has the skills to navigate that
world because you are graduates of the
West Hills obedience school before the
Dean hands out the diplomas I want to
ask you one more time
who's a good dog where's my check
[Applause]
you